like many of you you probably first
heard about Bitcoin around the time that
it first appeared on the the kind of
dock in 2008 was when Satoshi's first
paper came out and I think like many of
you at that point I was a little
concerned that this internet thing that
we had built on top of was resent relies
in a way I mean it was never really
totally decentralized and we can have an
interesting conversation during the QA
about the word decentralization but it
was certainly a place that felt
flattered right it was a place where you
could run your own mail server you could
run your own web site you could run a
lot of your own software you didn't have
to but the fact that you could was an
incredibly liberating kind of thing
right and there was just enough
decentralization on the internet that it
was spawned it was AI was a place where
a lot of new businesses could be formed
and I don't know if this makes me a good
ancestor or not but I along with some
others here were complicit in putting
the first ad banner on the web and I've
tell people I've been atoning for it
ever since but but even in those days it
felt like the internet was this
wide-open frontier that by 2008 it
didn't quite feel so much as like a
frontier it felt a little more like
things were organizing to get back to
perhaps what Thomas J Watson he was the
founder of IBM said which was maybe
there's only a market for actually five
of these computers in the world right it
turned out that they would be you know
Mike Microsoft Amazon Apple etc and so
at that point the the the launch of
Bitcoin kind of felt like like there
were a number of other projects along
these lines that were about a set of
developers going well can we just
reinvent the underlying protocols to not
have this you know centralizing network
effect right is there a way that we can
make it cheap again to and and create a
financial incentive and a protocol that
made it so that you could host things in
a decentralized way and didn't have to
worry about these centers of gravity
forming out there in the world you put
impossibly idealistic I resonated with
it but I had some issues with it too I
had some issues with the idea of
proof-of-work serving as the fundamental
basis for how this works and and and I
can go into it in a bit but
proof-of-work is basically burning CPU
power to run a lottery to figure out who
puts the next link in a chain which for
a lot of
as they start looking at this makes you
go I'm not so sure I want to get into
this I kind of call it the mercury
mining of our generation right and that
it's cool technically but also kind of
icky once you get into it and certainly
can leave a toxic legacy what I also was
concerned about was whether a
speculative financial instrument really
was the right way to build the web 3.0
right was there a risk that this would
be gamed the way that financial markets
have always been gamed and we would find
a whole new set of empires being built
out of thin air fairly or unfairly right
because the internet never felt that way
internet technologies and protocols
you've released a piece of software the
thousandth person to adopt it didn't
benefit from it less than the first
person to adopt it right in fact they
probably benefited more it was a
snowball effect that grew and grew and
so I stayed kind of away from from
Bitcoin much to again our family's
detriment I did not invest early on in
Bitcoin or the others but kept my eye on
it and it was when I kind of realized
that there was perhaps another take on
it which was to look at the technology
underneath cryptocurrencies to try to
understand was there something
innovative and unique there and a way to
detach it from some of these things that
felt weird that I decided to jump in
[Music]